the brilliant player with us to take us
through his thought process
linear was a fantastic game we were all
extolling the virtues of your moves
moves like uh
rook to d2 that one we loved certainly
queen back to e1 juicy
i know you probably wanted to sacrifice
a piece and go boom boom boom and
guarantee the brilliancy prize for
yourself but you must be proud of this
game yeah i'm obviously very very happy
with the with this game it's uh not
every day obviously that you win
such a game against a
guy like maxime so
yeah i'm very happy so he went for this
line which it's
very very dangerous for black
and uh then i got a very promising
position but uh rook d2 was i think the
the key move
because uh
um
other moves let's take a look at the
screen we can just uh chose some lines
um by the way when was your when were
you out of book your your own sense of i
knew i mean i i knew that this line is
uh that uh it's it's super tricky for
black this is the whole queen a4 bc4
because of this queen e4 very important
move uh intermediate because if i go
bishop c2 immediately then he has queen
c6
uh but but queen e4 is very strong uh
yeah bishop c2 queen c6 is is fine for
black
but after queen e4
i
i mean i knew that this was already
tricky for black maybe maybe he had to
play queen eight but instead of queen
desant but it feels like an impossible
move to play in a game if you
i mean if you don't know
it's i'm not sure if if it's holding for
black but queen d7 certainly
more natural and after yeah after ht
um i thought he was he he would take on
e4 and then go for this end game which
is also very unpleasant for black like
queen takes e4 g takes f7 and then rook
f7 bishop takes e4
and uh
this is uh yeah because if rook g7 there
is uh g6 and bishop d5
so black is still
uh in in deep trouble here but um let's
let's point out this line for our
viewers please yeah uh hg bishop d5 and
like kind of black king of faith because
of mate
nasty line
so you still had some play
clearly in this position yes that he
would have to worry about so he went
instead for the mating attack and forced
you to find some great moves yeah hg uh
queen of four queen e5 to an h4 and here
uh it looks of course very promising but
also black is is getting some counter
play with rook c5 from rook b8 so
initially i was thinking rook h2 for
example
and then black goes um
yeah just to show some line rook c5
uh rook h1 there's
takes g5
and
black escapes and f4 there's room q1
so
yeah f4 here and then rook b8
b3
i thought uh c takes b3
uh now if a b rook a5 so bishop takes
and then black has root takes b three a
b and rook a5
treading
queen a1 and if rook a2 here then
already after queen c3 uh black has um
counter play so this was the line that i
was trying to make work i was trying
also rook h3 and so on but when i when i
considered the move rook d2 i
immediately realized that it in this
last line
the rook uh
on on h1 is perfect and and the rook on
d2 then i have rook a2 at the end of the
line and it's uh it's an important
difference
so for example uh yeah i play rook d2 if
he goes for rook c5 then f4
this was the game he played f6 but if he
goes rook b8 then i go b3
and
cb bishop takes
and now if rook takes b3 ab rook a5 i
have rook a2 and it's obviously much
better to have my rook on h1 and then on
d1 so i'm i'm ready to play queen h
sound if the queen leaves and this is
this is winning so this was the main
this guy's good this is exactly right
that was the exact reasons why rook d2
was better than
rook h2 yeah and then f6 i also uh was
thinking about it but uh it looks uh
looks so bad that i mean it should be
winning here in more than one way i
found this queenie one which i thought
was also pretty nice
and also rook h6 is important because
rook h8 uh queen takes wasn't that clear
i mean maybe it's winning but uh yeah
queen takes and if queen is six king
jisan
and we were we were speculating on this
line as well but a lot of work ahead
yeah takes king takes and if queen the
six rook cc-8 and maybe
it should be winning but uh
there's no need to go for this if i have
a move like rook h6
uh sorry your your your main move uh
here
takes in queen d6 has is meant by rook
yeah i was i was thinking takes uh king
takes queen takes c6 but rook cc eight
and roxy c8 thank you i'm sorry yeah yes
and uh
there there's some work to do here still
work got it but rook h6 yeah six is very
strong and then i was kind of hoping for
uh i mean white is winning i saw it but
uh i was hoping for something like queen
f7
uh instead or queen d7 and i was going
to play rook takes g6
uh bishop g7 rook takes g7 see that
would have guaranteed you the brilliancy
prize right there the vote would have
been done maybe this is maybe the fact
that i'm showing all the lines now
[Applause]
oh yeah okay
in the consideration
[Laughter]
no
great game very satisfying you must be
very satisfied now you've leapfrogged
him and you're a plus two just an
amazing position in the tournament yeah
it's great so um
we still have of course half of the
tournament to go but
it's definitely a very nice position to
be in
absolutely well congratulations on a
beautiful performance indeed one that's
definitely going to get consideration
for the brilliancy prize and get your
rest and play some more like this so
there'll be no doubt that you'll win it
i'll try thank you